[Music]
so today we must cancel a group called
gen z grow our platform they're
in organization of alleged republican
grassroots activists in generation z
and their mission is to as the name
suggests grow the platform and forge a
new
and young and exciting and fresh path
for the gop but one thing you notice
about the plans to forge a new and
exciting
and fresh new path for the gop is that
the new and exciting and fresh new path
always tends to look and sound an awful
lot like the old path
every couple of years someone comes
along with a big idea for how to help
the republican party get with the times
and connect with the youth and
invariably the big idea is for it to
basically continue doing what it's been
doing all along
so the group put out an ad yesterday
which got some attention online let's
take a look at that
we are generation z
we are the most creative and eager
generation
despite all of the memes and contrary to
popular belief
we are not automatically democrats
sometimes
they just feel like they're the only
option equality
education the environment and
entrepreneurship the four
e's that are key to preserving the gop
in the long run
we're the most diverse generation in
american history
above all we are the generation ready to
lead our country
to a brighter future in the 21st century
let me introduce you to some of my
friends
we're going to show you how we're going
to do this on the conservative side of
the aisle
you know we talk a lot about equality
but conservatives need to be engaged
this means promoting an equality of
opportunity for all voices
no more litmus tests give people the
freedom and security to live their own
lives
as an immigrant from cote d'ivoire i
have benefited from world-class
education
right here in america it will help me
achieve my dreams
and eventually attain my citizenship but
my story is exception
not the rule we need to pursue education
reforms
that lift up all students right here in
the united states
i grew up in the rural midwest i saw
firsthand the importance of a natural
environment
not only does it matter to the
livelihood of millions of american
farmers
but it's also god's creation and which
we have a moral obligation to protect
gen z is independent we think freely but
in order to fulfill our full potential
we need the tools and climate to pursue
our passions
fulfill our dreams and enact positive
change
if we want to preserve the freedom and
security that we love
while winning the ideological battle
against the left
we must grow gen z's platform on the
right
can we at least get some like stylish
and cool young people if we're going to
do this
can't even get that well this is pretty
wild stuff so apparently what they're
saying
is that the republican party should talk
about things like
equality and opportunity and respecting
the
environment truly no one has ever
devised such a revolutionary plan as
this
these kids are trailblazers it's not as
though literally every politician
constantly yammers about all of those
things already
so bringing things back to reality it's
true of course that education
is an important issue but a phrase like
we need to pursue education reforms that
lift up all students
is meaningless the word reform is
meaningless
every politician wants to reform
everything but nothing ever happens
apparently reform involves standing in
front of a thing that you want to reform
and just shouting the word reform at it
and with education especially we are way
past the point where
mere reform can solve the problem anyway
this is like
suggesting that somebody with stage four
skin cancer simply
needs to wear more sunscreen that advice
would have been helpful a long time ago
but now
far more drastic measures are needed
what the republican party needs to be
talking about is how to extricate
american families
from their dependence on the government
school system
that is the problem now that's the kind
of reform we need it's a societal reform
at the deepest level and it will require
massive lifestyle changes for millions
of people so it is difficult
but it's necessary and it's also a truly
revolutionary and bold message and an
exciting message
because we're talking about transforming
society
it's a message that says no don't reform
the government education system
dismantle it tear it to the ground
gather up the pieces
and throw them into the sea and let no
one ever speak its name again
that should be our educational message
what are the other e's
the environments well the problem there
is that nobody cares about that
i'm here to tell you right now nobody
cares about the environment
okay few people will admit it
but nobody really cares i don't really
care
i don't think about it at all even the
people who pretend to care
don't really people generally understand
that you shouldn't litter
you shouldn't engage in the wanton
destruction of nature for no reason but
nobody's making significant and dramatic
changes to their lives in order to save
the environment or whatever
nobody's doing that or will do that
and that's okay because the environment
will be okay the planet is a pretty
resilient thing it's been around for
over 4 billion years
it's survived asteroids and super
volcano eruptions and many other
calamities
it'll be fine this isn't something we
need to spend time talking about and
anyway like i said
nobody actually cares
what about equality well here's another
thing that conservatives
don't need to talk about what is
equality anyway what kind of equality do
we want
is equality some sort of universal good
no
it's not a universal good and it's not
universally attainable
the only kind of equality that we need
to worry about
is equality under the law there
shouldn't be any laws which target or
disenfranchise people based on race sex
etc
the good news is that there are no such
laws targeting racial minorities or any
other approved
victim group with the exception of
asians the bad news
is that there are laws like affirmative
action which intentionally disadvantage
white people and asians
and we should be talking about that but
but not by turning it into a broad
stroke discussion
about equality and then there's
entrepreneurship
entrepreneurship sure entrepreneurship
is good
we want more of that and we want to
protect small business owners and all of
that yada yada
um but are any of these issues the sorts
of issues that really drive
people at the deepest level are these
the things that
stir men's souls are people lying awake
at night
tossing and turning worried about these
kinds of things are people sitting at
their kitchen
tables right now you know furrowing
their brows
rubbing their temples fretting about
whether we have the right environmental
policies in place
no is anyone going to see that ad that i
just played and feel fired up and ready
to charge into battle eager to fight for
the soul of our nation
no we live in a country
where life sanity
reason virtue science
truth are all under attack
at the most fundamental level our nation
itself our sovereignty hangs in the
balance
the most powerful forces in our culture
from government to academia to media
to corporate america are all conspiring
in this assault
and that is what worries people that's
what keeps people awake at night young
and old and in between i know because
they tell me all the time
these are not academic issues either
these are real and tangible and these
are things
that republican leaders and lawmakers
could be doing something
to stop they could be addressing it
we could have laws in place around all
of these issues
but we're not doing anything and and
that's what the conservative movement
of the future should be focused on if
it's not focused on that then it might
as well put up the white flag and
surrender and that's what this ad is
really proposing in so many words
what it's really saying is there's a lot
of words to really just say
give up
and that's why the ad and those
responsible for it
are as tradition dictates canceled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated